yeah the married couple at the beginning
of this movie has nobody seen the movie
thinner does thin or not exist in zombie
movies
if texting and driving is dangerous
just saying i always think of thinner
[Music]
army of the dead so army of the dead's a
new zombie movie we've had night of the
living dead
dawn of the dead day of the dead land of
the dead now army of the dead though
army of the dead is not
connected it's just a name it's gotta be
of the dead it's directed by zack snyder
while the internet was like release the
snyder cut while the internet is like
restore the snyder verse zack snyder's
like
here's a zombie movie with a very unique
take i kind of want to call the premise
of this movie genius it's pretty genius
because
vegas casino heist movie we've seen that
zombie survival movie we've seen that
merge them you have my curiosity also
among this zombieland
there are advanced zombies that are very
tribal very intelligent very coordinated
now you have my attention
what i liked about this movie is batista
really carries this whole thing
batista's shown that
he's a great support character he's a
great addition to any cast now he's
shown
he can carry a movie he's a great action
star but also in this movie he really
brings the emotion and the heart which
he has done before
even with his limited screen time and
blade runner 2049 that was the moment i
was like
so this guy's not just a beefy action
guy he's
he can bring it action comedy relief and
heart the man is a triple threat
but i was impressed with him in this
movie the movie actually has a really
good ensemble of characters
it's exaggerated in that zack snyder
kind of way like they've been pulled
from a comic book because they're
exaggerations of
what they should be you know like you
have the safe cracker who is definitely
the little safe cracker nerd who should
not be going into a zombie infested
waistline but he is in the friendship he
starts to form with one of the other
characters it just it really does
work my favorite of the characters was
the pilot you don't see a lot of her
but the moment you do i was like she's
probably going to be my favorite she's a
cynical sarcastic smart ass and
what can i say i like those characters i
feel a keenship to the cynical
and sarcastic i'll bet you she thinks of
the movie thinner too and you can't help
but be pulled in by the premise of this
movie there's already this
devilish nature to las vegas so the fact
that
hell's pretty much sprung up in las
vegas
is fittings like the adult playground of
the world
has turned into another adult playground
of the world because
if people aren't fantasizing about going
to vegas they're fantasizing about
shooting zombies
now you get to do both also in true zack
snyder fashion you do
see what zack snyder loves which is i
mean other than a colorful
ensemble of characters slo-mo and depth
of field the man
loves his slow-mo and he loves that
depth of field
and his insane run time i i don't
remember his movies being that insane
it's like he was like wait i just pumped
out a four-hour movie
time to get crazy with run times from
now on then again batman vs superman the
theatrical version was two and a half
hours
so is this that's the reason i'm getting
this to you a little late last night i
was just i
was feeling under the weather just
feeling blessed i don't think i have a
zombie virus or anything
um jury's still out but i was like okay
army of the dead
and holy two and a half hour long movie
um
i'm usually a night owl uh but i'm gonna
go to sleep but for this movie i felt
the two and a half hours in here more
than i felt the four hours of justice
league
there are a lot of irons in the fire in
here and i don't think they're
needed to be like the daughter like why
does batista's character bring his
daughter along i mean there's a story
based reason as to why she wants to go
which really leads to [ __ ] all in the
movie that's another thing i know why
the daughter's in it because you want to
have those
heartfelt father-daughter moments in
this movie bring in the heart and all
that that's the thing i liked about
batista in here also the actress
as the daughter thought she was fine
just the character being
in it in this situation i didn't buy it
i think he'd be like um
no on a judgment call as much as you
want to go in there
no in a world where i'm replaying the
mass effect games if batista's character
had his paragon or renegade up to a
point he could have talked his way out
of that and you don't get the onslaught
of zombies that i wanted to see in this
movie
until the end granted last half hour of
this movie it's on
it's definitely on and it's a bloody
good time movie's pretty violent
you should know that not just violent
but zombie apocalypse violent a lot of
arteries get
bitten off a lot of heads go bam you
know it's a different kind of violence
in the end army of the dead is a perfect
hour and 45 minute long movie
or two hour long movie that's been
padded to be two and a half hours long
but it's still a fun movie i still
enjoyed myself in it if you're looking
for
one of the great zombie movies of all
time that just threads the needle keeps
it in the pocket
between great pacing character
development and thrills not quite there
but if you're going into a zack snyder's
zombie survival movie
slash bank heist movie that takes place
in las vegas that'll be over the top
stylish over-the-top violent
over-the-top with the slow-mo scenes
that'll be a bloody good time might feel
like it's a bit too long and
feel like it drags on in parts i think
you'll have a good time with it i did i
got it in the form of a fun time no
alcohol required it's like recently as
of late
people give zack snyder [ __ ] because he
doesn't make
stanley kubrick or milos foreman movies
or something it's like that's
that's not him he makes stuff like this
he knows who he's making it for you're
one of his fans i think he'll enjoy this
there is a i don't want to say it's a
plot hole but it feels like what i'm
looking forward to the how it should
have ended video they might make about
army of the dead
i mean if they do i don't know if they
will but i feel like they will touch on
this thing
where it's like if that had happened
back an hour into the movie this movie
would have been an hour long you would
have saved an hour and a half you seemed
like a bit of a plot hole it stands out
to me alright so army of the dead have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you